24 year old jonathan heasley here are
his numbers with double a northwest
arkansas he goes from double a right to
the big leagues oh you know just a
wonderful moment for he and his family
for sure this young man here he looks
focused hopefully he can just be you be
who you are
and a fly ball into center field lopez
goes way out taylor comes in and with
father rick mom sherry and wife taylor
and others are cheering his first big
league out the change up looks good
good pitch on the corner
and he is wise to get out of salvi's way
but the five-time gold glover make the
play
and there are two down
fly ball
that should end the inning then comes
ben and tendy and boy that's as good a
start as jonathan heasley could hope for
right-hander chris flexon flex an eleven
and six
with a three point seven three era in 27
starts
right pretty cold
barnfield thought he had a freebie not
so one out it's perfectly located
fastball from the fourth seamer right on
the outside corner at the knees so well
done kellnick with 10 homers 31 runs
batted in nine doubles 3-1 pitch
to kelnick oh he got into that keep it
fair stay fair gone there we go two run
jack like jk jared kelneck home run
number 11 rbi 32 and 33 in a two nothing
mariner lead you really have to like
this right here he gets himself into a
three one count and that's a change up
87 miles an hour so you would think
you're going to get 94.95 i said it's
87. he lets the ball travel and just
puts the barrel on it exit velo of 111
that's crushed every bit
blasted absolutely blasted well done ap
at first base al seger flew out last
time crawford runs that's a strikeout
and that
is a double play it's a strike about
throw him out double play
on the first strike out of the young
career of jonathan heasley walsh two
strikes as flexin stares in
brings it to the glove from the belt
he's ready
here comes his pitch
strike three called he froze him nice
cutter right at the bottom corner of the
strike zone a beautiful pitch picture
perfect chris flexon off to a nice start
he's kept the royals off the board
through three and one away and that'll
bring up jared kelnick kelnick one for
one with a big one a home run to right
field
center field and deep taylor giving
chase looking up bye-bye
a two-home run game for jared kelnick
he's got two two-run blasts to the
mariners have a four nothing lead he is
in a groove hey you know i have a better
idea why i got turtles three and oh mike
that's exactly right
seven pitches in the at-bat and
everything was away from him this last
pitch another off speed pitch here's the
breaking ball it's on the outside corner
but it's barrelled up he goes straight
away center fifth home run of the month
four rbis for celtic what a night for
the kid today that jonathan heasley and
his family will never forget you go out
there give up a couple of home runs but
he worked quickly he threw strikes he
stayed on the attack he wasn't it he
didn't appear to be intimidated
hopefully a great learning experience
for jonathan heasley he's a big leaguer
now he is
so tyler zuber royals at least on paper
have 11 relievers available out in the
bullpen and that's come in handy on this
home stand
that's what they're looking for
so a good adjustment from pitch to pitch
he recognized that he tried to over spin
the one before and got back into it yeah
blue kc pitch track shows you the arc on
that break and we're ended and that's
exactly where you want to finish
barefield at second perez at first best
threat so far tonight against flexon
and he's going to drop that one into
left field whit read it right away so he
got a good jump and the royals are on
the board
andrew benintendi has driven in 18
in his last nine games stay hot and you
know he's giving him that side of the
field and here's a cutter that's up and
kind of in on him but you know he's able
to keep his hands inside
of the baseball with a good level swing
on contact and he
hit it soft
but it hit them outfield grass and
knocks in another run beautiful job keep
a little two out rally going here
so full count this will give salvi and
andrew benintendi a head start as salvi
leaves from second ben attendee from
first infield swung around to the right
there they go the pitch and it's high
ball four and they're loaded for
michael a taylor scott service is gonna
go out and bring in a guy who's real
tough on right-hand batters and here
comes joe smith takes a practice cut
smith his pitch strike three called he
throws him right at the bottom corner of
the strike zone a perfect pitch as smith
lets out a bellow as he gets out of a
bases loaded jam in the sixth inning
many
and they turn safe pull him off the bag
oh that works
run scores
i thought they were going to be able to
turn it mirrorfield was able to get rid
of it quickly even though it was kind of
on the hands of j.p crawford
sam holbrook the crew chief they're
looking at it and he's saying his foot
was not on the base there it is you
could see him pull off yeah
there's separation
there you go there you go that will work
jp and rbi
choice rbi and a 5-1 marital lead
terence scores 5-1 seattle lead as the
royals come up in the bottom of the
seventh inning and hunter dozier will
lead things off
dozier lifts it to right hanger is back
it is gone
dozier helps get that run right back
first pitch
opposite field it's his 13th of the
season
yes he caught it just right fastball up
he supplied the power at 94.
did second rider and and dozier he just
put a nice easy swing on it and once
again another extra base hit for dozier
so it's five two
one and two two terrence
and through the gap right center field
that's a base head
coming around this score kyle seeger
marin and they got the
runner hung up that's france
and
america one of the fastest guys in the
league puts the final out on it but the
good news the run scores here is
castillo
to take over in relief the 1-2 to perez
swinging a ground ball at third kyle's
got it tossed across in time and the
ball game is over the mariners win it a
final score of six to two to take the
opening game of the road trip